we'll see a familiar face tonight
anchoring the CBS Evening News Jeff Glor
is taking charge of the broadcast he has
spent the past decade reporting around
the world for CBS News Jeff is now
sharing some of his favorite stories
ahead of tonight's launch with NASA we
went up in an f-18 249 thousand feet to
try to create a sonic boom that is
quieter than the normal sonic boom I did
not throw up I got all kinds of training
and thank goodness I never had to use
the longest an outsider has lasted
inside the chamber is 45 minutes so we
let him lock me in do people worry about
the Gators and the snakes
now that the shark is on the list this
is when a scientist do their work the
shark tagging story was the confluence
of science and adventure never mind the
drama of how it all came to be
that was out of a movie nothing made me
happier than having a baby has anything
made you happier no nothing no no one of
the best parts of the interview process
for me is searching as we go along what
does he have on this is an EEG we're
looking at what seems to be one body
there but it's actually two brains yes
if you're standing on this corner 25
years ago and you see that kid pull that
gun out what do you say to him it's not
working I'll tell you what's worth it
Jeff Flores sitting in their chair at
CBS Evening News Jeff Glor
congratulations number one I have no
doubt in my mind that you were ready but
I am curious about how you're feeling I
get a little kick walking in the studio
and there's Walter Cronkite's map yeah
but you're gonna be the one sitting in
the chair that was once set in that what
you're holding the job that Walter
Cronkite once had Wow Wow Wow yeah I
mean it some nerves are good right means
you yeah it's a good job no matter what
so and when I did stories for for 60
minutes sports I worked with a producer
who was one of Walter's guys in the late
70s and 80s a guy with an email and
Weissman I had a lot of chances spent a
lot of time with him
from him tried to pull as much knowledge
as I could but I mean the roots run very
deep here it seems I thought it's
interesting I read that you've reached
out to other anchors I try all of them
yeah I've spoken to all of them at this
point we've had this job in the past
this network or others and all of them
have been extraordinarily generous with
their time what did you want to know
what what I should be looking out for
what I'm not looking out for what how
what I should do and and all of them
have had different pieces of advice to
sort of round all that out and I have to
just been that's been one of the true
joys for me in this process is hearing
from them and and how they can help what
stories can we look forward to in the
first week well the president will be in
Utah talking about national monuments
today we're gonna be dealing with that
as well tonight there's we're going to
talk about an 11 year old girl who came
up with a lead test after the Flint
water crisis you'll hear more about that
tonight
and much more in the in the days and
weeks to come so we've all followed your
amazing career and your reporting chops
and anchoring chops you're more than
qualified for the job but people that
follow you on social media really know
what a family man you are as well your
beautiful wife Nikki two kids Jack
Victoria how do they feel about their
daddy sitting in that big chair I know
they're the bosses at home yeah they
could care less they could care less
they just got a big new job we took them
to the we took them by the White House
briefing room yesterday Jack and
Victoria and I said I said guys for like
11 and a half minutes can you cooperate
yeah you like not and not yell or scream
just for like ten minutes of your life
and it did those lasted like that how
are you going to balance it all good
question it's tough I'm you have to
carve out those I mean that was one of
the pieces of advice deal that I got
from one of the people is that you have
to find that off switch every once in a
while you have you have to carve out you
certainly have to carve out the time for
family but then just for yourself when
you have those moments
it won't happen for a little while at
least but it's it's a it's a trick well
they may not understand the big deal of
the job because you said that when it
was first announced you spent that night
changing a diaper and reading a book so
let's hope that that never changes it's
not preclude me from doing did you grow
up watching CBS Evening News
you did all right I did before after our
local news and wiv be in Buffalo buffalo
yeah man from Buffalo know one day Jeff
someone's gonna you know I grew up
watching Jeff Glor on CBS a few years
bread's - Congrats
that's game we're very excited thank you
guys you can see the debut of CBS
Evening News was Jeff Glor it's about
ten hours from now tonight at 6:30
Eastern right here on CBS